[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
OK, so let me say
a couple of words about where
we are in the reading list.
We're going to start today.
We're done with the segment on
contracts and mechanism design,
theory and applications.
And we start today, Walrasian
General Equilibrium,
which you've seen a
bit before already.
But we'll review and give
the proper definitions
for the first 20%
of the lecture.
And then the rest
of the lecture is
devoted to an
important application
of General Equilibrium theory.
And in particular, it
has to do with trade.
So this lecture
today is the theory,
with some really startling
and interesting propositions.
And then with
trade on our minds,
we'll go back to the Thai
data, and take a look
at trade flows and
financial flows that
have changed over time
as the country became
more liberalized, or
more open internally.
And then we're going to go to
a parallel lecture on the US
that's going to look at
trade flows and potentially
financial flows across
states in the US,
where we'll be analyzing
the impact of tariffs,
and/or China shocks--
China imports.
So these, dare I say it, it
may or may not be on your mind.
If it's on your mind
already, the motivation
here is a US policy decision
which is very much in the news,
and in some respects, a big
part of the upcoming election.
So I don't know if the timing of
these lectures are good or bad.
But anyway, we'll be talking
about US trade policy
within two lectures.
So that's what's coming up.
And today's lecture has got
two start readings, the Kreps
book on section 6.1, and
this Mas-Colell, Whinston,
and Green.
I rarely assign this book.
But on the other
hand, the lecture
is based very closely
on that chapter.
So I went ahead and just
listed it, MWG chapter 15 D,
although it's quite
a famous model.
We've been using MWG in
the theorems and so on.
But I've never really
featured it so heavily.
In terms of the overall--
just to see it in one
spot, again, we're
going to do Walrasian
equilibrium, and then
two applications of trade
in Thailand and the US.
That's actually
going to complete--
lecture 15 completes the
current segment of lectures
before the second exam.
So problem set 4, which was
released last-- the last thing
I want to do before
getting to the lecture
is to review a bit of
what we did last time.
I deliberately didn't pick
out very many questions here.
Allow risk aversion on
the part of the borrower.
There are several
advantages to writing down
programs in lotteries.
List two of them and explain.
So let's see if I can get some--
Charles, do you want to
take a crack at that?
AUDIENCE: I think I can guess
one, definitely at least one
of them, which, if I
remember correctly,
is that it allows you
to make an incentive.
You may select between
people with high income
and low income, if you don't
know the income already.
So like, if you're risk
averse in the correct manner,
then if you have a lottery,
then someone with low income
might prefer a lottery with
something like-- you might
prefer the different risk return
trade off at different incomes.
There's a dislike
between various things,
and help with some
of the constraints.
The other one, I don't
remember the exact details.
I haven't quite got them yet.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: The
first one is good.
AUDIENCE: I'm going to
guess something like,
maybe making people not
as willing to borrow
or something like that.
But I'm not exactly sure.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Let's see.
Kerry, can you get
one more of them?
AUDIENCE: Is it, like,
incentive constraints
could be non-convex.
So it might be hard to solve.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, good.
So there's various
sources of non-convexity.
So those incentive
constraints, when
written without the lotteries,
like first order conditions
of the borrower's
choice of effort.
Those things can lead
to non-convexity.
So by doing it in lotteries,
we get that problem solved.
And also, if there is
some indivisibilities,
that would be solved.
There are two indivisibilities
in this problem.
One has to do with
occupation choice.
You're either a wage
earner or an entrepreneur.
That's a binary choice.
So the lotteries kind
of smooth that over
because you can effectively
choose the probability.
And secondly, there could
be individual abilities
in the discreteness
of the capital grid.
Like, you're going to capitalize
a high amount or a low amount.
And again, lotteries help
with that indivisibility.
OK, so the next one is really
a summary of what we did.
But let me read it out.
Sketch out how one can take
the model with the lotteries
to the data on
occupation choice,
and estimate parameters.
So can anyone attempt a
summary of what we did
last time on that dimension?
Pablo?
AUDIENCE: Sure, I can
take a stab at this.
So I think the way
that we did it was we--
given these different parameters
that we had, of ability,
education, and wealth, we solved
for this optimal contract,
theoretically.
And then we made a
likelihood function to--
given these solutions,
to see which one of these
is like going to be like
the best, essentially.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Do you remember
how we did, quote, "the best?"
The best in terms of what?
AUDIENCE: Just kind of, like,
the likelihood function,
trying to maximize that.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, OK.
Yeah, so the likelihood
function tells us
the probability of what
we are seeing in the data
if the model were true.
So we're choosing parameters
to make that probability
as high as possible.
OK, that's good.
Any other questions
about that lecture?
All the other questions
at the beginning
here were basically, write
it down the way we did it
in class, et cetera, et cetera.
So it's not exactly
conducive to asking you
these questions in class.
But it is important to
be reviewing these review
questions.
All right, so then we
come to the lecture today.
This is Walrasian equilibria
with an application to trade.
And we're going to consider
trade, for the most part,
in a small open economy.
Although we'll say a little bit
about putting the world pieces
together at the very end.
So here's the notation,
which is largely
a review because you have
seen almost all of it before.
When we write down an economy,
we mean the commodity space,
in this case, capital L, a
finite number of commodities.
I is the number of consumers.
J is the number of firms--
finite for each.
Household or consumer,
I, has a consumption set.
And preferences over bundles
in the consumption set, as for,
example, represented
by a utility function.
Each firm, J, has a technology
production possibility
set in the same L
dimensional space.
And the economy has
exogenously given endowments,
according to this L
dimensional endowment vector,
with the bars being
the aggregates.
So that's the economy.
Now, in, say, a private
ownership economy, we
have to specify, in
addition, who owns what.
So we imagine that consumer
I has an endowment vector, L
dimensional, subscript
I, for consumer, I.
And it is the sum of
these endowments over all
the household that adds
up to the omega bar L
dimensional endowment vector
on the previous slide.
Aggregates naturally come from
the individual's ownership.
Each consumer, in addition
to having endowments,
has some share of
the profits of firms.
So theta, IJ, being the
share that household, I, has,
of J's profits.
So these are meant to be
a division of the profit.
So the sum of the shares
over households, I,
for a given firm,
J, add up to 1.
Everything gets distributed.
And household I is getting theta
IJ of pi J, for firm, J. Now,
pi J is obviously an
endogenous object.
It could be 0 if there were
constant returns to scale.
It could be positive if
there are diminishing returns
to scale.
And also, when we did risk and
return in village economies,
we kind of naturally had
an interesting and relevant
special case that household
I gets all the profits
from the activities
that it undertakes.
In that case, there was a
household, I, and a firm,
I. It was the same entity.
And household I was
getting theta IJ
equal to 1 of its own
profits, as a special case.
But general equilibrium
theory usually
allows something more general.
And you could think of
this literally as a market
economy, where the shares are
equity shares being traded.
And all of the
dividends are claimed
by the ownership of shares.
OK, so a private
ownership economy
has a summary of
the consumption,
set preferences,
endowments of consumer
I, the production sets of
all the house firms, J,
and the shares, theta IJ.
Now we get to the
big definition here.
In this L dimensional
commodity space,
a price vector, p, is the price
of all the commodities, inputs,
and outputs, and everything.
And a Walrasian equilibrium,
or competitive equilibrium
for short, for this
private ownership economy,
is a specification of
allocations with stars on them,
x and y star, for
consumers and firms--
and a price vector star here
because it's a special price.
Allocations and prices have
the special properties.
Each firm, J, has y
star J as the maximum
of the firm's problem, which
is to maximize profits.
Hence, at y star, the valuation
of outputs less inputs
is weakly greater than it
would be for any other choice
of production vector.
Each consumer, i, is maximizing
relative to the preference
ordering on bundles in the
consumption set, but also
subject to the
budget constraint,
that expenditures at price
p star, for any xi that
could potentially be chosen--
cannot exceed the
right hand side,
which is the private
ownership part.
So omega i, being the
endowments of consumer,
i, evaluated at price p star,
that dot is inner product.
And again, household i's claim
on the profits of firm, J.
And the final property
is that the allocation
has to be feasible.
And you can just read this as
demand cannot exceed supply,
where supply includes both
the aggregated endowment
and production.
So we worked a lot with
feasibility before.
We did that when we
defined Pareto optimality.
The difference here
in general equilibrium
or Walrasian
equilibrium is we've
added this price vector
explicitly, and rewritten
consumer maximization
problem, on which we've
had several lectures.
And firms-- sorry, I
reversed the order--
firms max and
consumers max problems.
So everything's in one spot.
OK, so a classic example
is the Edgeworth Box.
We previously defined
Pareto optimal allocations
in this box, as
characterized by tangencies
of indifference curves.
Here we add one more
ingredient, that if they
start with this endowment,
and we draw a price line
through the endowment, then
each consumer is maximizing
utility, subject to its budget.
So consumer 1 here has the
normal-looking budget line.
And coming from the endowment
and the tangency at x star
would be the maximum.
You may remember consumer
2 up here on the northeast
is moving to the southwest in
terms of increased utility,
and is also maximizing
utility, which
is achieved by a tangency on
that consumer's budget line.
So this line here is
doing double duty.
It's a budget line
for each household.
But the perspective is
at or below consumer 1,
at or above the
line for consumer 2.
And here you're seeing the
star allocations, which
are a competitive equilibrium.
Everything in the box adds up to
the aggregates by construction.
There is no production.
They're all maximizing utility.
And the price vector is
characterized by the slope
of this budget line.
Now, we could go on with
a lot more interesting,
and some nonstandard pictures,
of the Edgeworth Box.
But we're going to save a lot
of that for another lecture.
Here, I defined
Walrasian equilibrium.
I wanted to find something
similar but not identical.
It's a price equilibrium
with transfers.
So here, the idea is
that the right hand
side is a wealth assignment.
Household, i, has
wealth, w sub i.
So the rest is similar.
We're going to have an
allocation with stars--
a price vector, p, which
should have had stars on it
because it's a special one--
with the property,
and an assignment
of these wealth levels, such
that firms maximize profits.
That's the same as before.
Households maximize utility.
But the right hand side of the
budget is this wealth object.
And again, when we did partial
equilibrium consumer problem,
we talked about
prices and wealth.
We had income expansion
paths as wealth varied.
So this formulation
of the problem
is consistent with that.
Although in partial
equilibrium, we
didn't ask where that
wealth was coming from.
An allocation is feasible.
Again, demand cannot be greater
than the two sources of supply.
Now the wealth assignments
have to be feasible.
And here's where we
can say something
about where wealth
is coming from,
namely, the sum of the
wealths, whatever they are,
have to equal the valuation of
the aggregated endowment vector
plus the profits
of all the firms.
So somehow, this stuff
on the right hand side
gets distributed across the
households, each household, i,
getting wealth, wi.
And when we add it
up, therefore, it
sums up to the right hand side.
Now note that at the bottom
here, a particular wealth
assignment that works is what
we had on the previous slide,
namely, give household, i, the
valuation of its endowment,
plus its share of the profits
of the firms that it owns.
So in that sense, a price
equilibrium with transfers
is more general, but includes
the valuation equilibrium.
That said, the word
transfers may catch your eye.
And the idea here is that
a Walrasian equilibrium
with ownership specifies
one level of wealth.
But we could, in principle,
redistribute that wealth
by the government
with lump sum taxes
and transfers, and then look
for a new priced equilibrium.
And we will-- I think it's
on the next slide, yeah.
We will get to why
we're doing this.
Namely, any Walrasian
equilibrium is Pareto-optimal.
But it's also true that any
Pareto-optimal allocation
can be supported as
a price equilibrium
with transfers, as
in this definition.
However, to achieve the
fact that any optimum can
be supported, it's
kind of intuitive.
We may have to
redistribute wealth.
And again, I have a series
of lectures on this.
But if we're back in
the Edgeworth Box,
the competitive
equilibrium has picked
out one particular
Pareto-optimal allocation.
But as there are many
optimal allocations--
and to get to those,
we're going to have
to move this budget
line up or down, hence,
redistributing the wealth.
OK, so now that we've got
the concept of the Walrasian
equilibrium in hand,
I want to focus
on the primary application
today, which is production
in a small open economy.
We have to shift gears
just a little bit.
It's definitely going to
be general equilibrium.
We're going to have J firms.
And firms are producing goods.
So they're J goods
because we have J firms.
Firm J produces good, qJ.
And there are L
factors of production,
labeled, in this
case, Z. So Z1J is
the input of the first
factor by firm, J, and so on.
And each firm, J, has a strictly
concave production function,
indicated here by f sub J.
Output of consumer good, qJ,
is a function of the
input vector, ZJ.
So now we specify endowments.
The endowments are going to
be given of the factor inputs.
They're owned by households.
And for the sake of
argument, let's say they're
supplied in-elastically.
And they're not
going to be consumed.
What we're going to try to
do is find the factor prices
that's consistent
with an equilibrium
within this small open economy.
However, we're going to take the
prices of the goods as fixed.
So in that sense, it's
still partial equilibrium.
Think of it as a village,
as a small open economy
or a country, that
is small relative
to the rest of the world so that
these price vectors are fixed.
They're not going to be
the focus of our attention.
We are going to,
however, try to find
the allocation of the inputs
across all the firms, how
those endowments of
factors get used,
as well as the Walrasian
equilibrium price vector.
So firm j producing good qj
will maximize the difference
between revenues and costs.
So if w star, say, is a
candidate equilibrium price
vector, the firm would
choose its input vectors, Zj,
to maximize revenue minus costs
at that guessed equilibrium
price vector, w star.
p is, again, a given-- pj,
the price of quantity, j,
is externally specified.
So Z star j is the solution to
firm j's maximization problem.
And if we're finding
an equilibrium,
each firm will be
maximizing profits
and the sum of
the input demands,
in this case, the demand for
the L-th input from firm,
j, summing over all the
firms j, and in particular
the stars, which are
already profit-maximizing,
add up to the economy's
endowment of the factor, Z bar,
for the L-th factor.
And this is true for all,
each and every, factor,
L. This one is true for
each and every firm, j.
So this is what we're looking
for, the Walrasian equilibrium
in the factor markets, taking
external prices as given.
All right, you already know
something about the solutions
to the profit
maximization problem.
Namely, the value of
the marginal product
should be equal to--
of the L factor,
should be equal to its cost.
Just differentiate this
thing on the previous slide.
With respect to zj, you'll get
a derivative in the F function,
and will get the factor
input price on the cost side.
That's what this says.
Factor input price--
here's the derivative of F,
with respect to the L factor.
And that p is, of course, part
of the exogenously-given price
vector.
How many equations
are there like this?
Well, we have to specify here.
It's the L factor.
And we have L--
capital L factors all together.
And this is for the j firm.
But we have capital J firms.
So we have L times
J equations here.
And we have another
set of equations
which are the equilibrium,
that the demand for the factors
adds up to the total.
But again, this is true for
each and every L-th factor.
So there are L of these guys.
So we have L times
J equations here.
And we have L equations here.
So the number of equations
is equal to the number
of variables.
So in principle, we
should be able to solve
this system of equations to
determine the equilibrium
factor prices.
It's tedious and
boring to keep counting
the number of variables.
But it is actually useful to
see if we have fully specified,
and we potentially
have a solution.
So now, we've already
solved in lecture 4,
which was about production,
a cost minimization problem.
So we defined there
the cost for firm J
of producing the quantity, qj,
when the input vector was w.
I must say, even I
went back this morning
in reviewing this lecture to
take a look at the earlier
lecture.
Today there's kind of an uneasy
tension because I'm partially
telling you things that you've
had before, on the other hand,
aware that you may not remember
exactly what we had before.
If you go back and look,
it'll all come back to you.
And some of these
slides are actually
repeats of what
was in lecture 4.
Anyway, when we
derived the least cost
way of producing
an output, qj, we
got that marginal cost
was equal to price.
It's equal.
Marginal cost is from your very
first economics micro course,
probably.
Now, this second
equation is the equation
that the demands for the
factors adds up to the total.
But it's written
in an interesting
and a bit unconventional way.
The aggregate amount of factor
l that's available is z bar l.
And we want the demands of
these firms for producing.
But instead, we use
the Shephard's lemma,
the derivative of
the cost of firm j,
with respect to the
price of the l-th factor,
we derived as the amount of
the l-th factor to be used.
And again, you may or may
not remember that that's
the Shephard's lemma.
Here it is, written
down here at the bottom.
So we just substitute
what was written as zlj,
summation over j equal to z
bar, we substitute in the result
from Shephard's lemma
to get this equation
OK, special case, 2 by 2.
And there'll be another
two coming later.
But for now, two types
of firms, J equals 1, 2--
two inputs.
Now, it's useful to think of
the inputs as labor and capital.
And that, in fact, will
anticipate the trade
applications.
Are we reproducing
goods with machines?
Are we producing
goods with labor?
What happens to the
labor when we have
a decline in manufacturing?
It comes from
having more inputs.
So these are the kind of
ingredients, labor and capital
being kind of obvious labels
for us, in the case of this two
factor model.
Production functions,
just to write out
the notation, production
function for good 1, as it
inputs, the second
subscript denotes the firm,
the first one, the input.
So this is the first
input in firm 1,
the second input in firm 1.
f2 is output of
firm 2 as a function
of the first input
in for firm 2,
and the second input for firm 2.
And we're going to
assume, in this special 2
by 2 model, that these
production functions, each
of them, are constant
returns to scale.
So it's homogeneity of degree 1.
So if we're given a
vector of input prices
for capital and
labor, we can define
the cost of producing
one unit of good, j.
This is called the unit cost--
or you may want to review that
the cost of producing arbitrary
levels just scales
up or down depending
on whether that
other target level is
higher or lower than 1.
So once we have the cost
of producing one unit,
we can get the cost of
producing any number of units.
And what inputs solve
that minimum cost problem?
They're denoted with a's.
So for firm j, a1j
and a2j are the way
to achieve the least cost
when the input vector is w.
Input price vector
is w So here I
belabor a little bit
what you've seen before.
It's constant returns to scale.
So the cost function is linear.
Constant returns to scale
is this linear production
possibilities frontier.
Cost function is linear.
Marginal cost
equals average cost.
If price of a good,
say good j, is
less than marginal and average
cost, nothing gets produced.
And when price is equal to
marginal and average cost,
then they're happy
to produce anything.
Although profits are 0.
And price cannot be higher
because they would go bananas.
And then the assertion, which
I've already said twice,
profits must be zero.
And that's just, again, a
review slide from before.
So price equals cost.
This is the unit cost.
Price is the price of a unit.
So we have cost equal to prices.
OK, so another review.
We did this before, too.
What's special about
constant returns
to scale is we can solve
the problem for the one
unit of output,
minimize the cost
of achieving one unit of output.
And that's going to give us--
I guess I just
said this, the cost
for any other level of output,
just by scaling up and down
the solution.
And the ratios of input
use will not be changing.
I think in the previous
lecture, I actually
said I wasn't terribly
pleased with how
cryptically-worded it was.
And I gave you as an
informal homework assignment
to do a proof by contradiction
to prove that the input use
ratio is going to
be entirely dictated
by the input prices,
regardless of the scale.
That is to say, this input
ratio will remain constant.
And again, please, I apologize
because I'm throwing at you
things from a previous lecture.
It was lecture 4.
So that was some time ago.
But I don't want
to belabor it today
or we won't get
to something new.
So for now, we'll just
accept this as a fact.
Then we come to a key definition
about factor intensity.
Say good 1 is more intensive
in factor 1 than good 2.
Then the production of
good 2, if naturally,
firm producing good 1 uses
relatively more of input 1--
input 1 relative to input
2, then does firm 2.
So the definition, to say
good 1 is relatively more
intensive than factor 1, means
that the ratio of factor 1
to factor 2 in firm 1 is
higher than it is in firm 2.
So it's a pretty
natural definition.
Of course, it can move around.
But the inequality
remains the same.
It's intense.
No matter what the
input price ratio is,
the optimizing choice
of inputs will always
satisfy this inequality when
comparing firm 1 to firm 2.
So now something a bit new
that was not in lecture 4,
although it's not hard.
We're going to plot the cost of
producing one unit of a good.
We're going to plot that
cost curve as a function
of the input prices, w1 and w2.
So in particular, if, say,
for a given w1 and w2 bar,
your assertion is we're
on this cost curve,
then if we increase the price
of the first input to w prime 1
and we're supposed
to be on an isocost,
meaning same cost
curve, the increase
in the first factor price would
mean the cost would be higher.
So we have to lower the
price of the second factor
in order to compensate.
So that on net, after
we make this move,
total costs are the same
because it is the isocost curve.
So this down-sloping nature
of the isocost curve,
plotted against various input
prices, makes a lot of sense.
The other thing is
this concave shape.
This comes from a property
of the minimized cost.
In particular, this set of input
prices at or above the cost
line is a convex set.
But we did this a
lot with respect
to the consumer
optimization problem.
We defined quasi-concave utility
functions and the associated
concave indifference curves.
And we had the
weak upper contour
set as being strictly convex.
So these are analogs here.
Now, the assertion is that
this cost function is, in fact,
concave.
And again, as a review--
but who remembers?
We already had
derived in lecture 4
that the cost function is
concave in the input prices.
So I just pasted in
the slide to remind us.
So now we have
down-sloping concave.
And the other thing
that's going on here
is, at these particular
input prices,
if we go back to
Shephard's lemma,
the derivative of
the minimized cost,
with respect to, say, the
price of the first factor,
is the level input
of the first factor,
and similarly, for the level
input of the second factor.
So the ratio, the slope
of this line, which
is the ratio of the
derivatives of the cost
curve at an optimum,
must, by Shephard's lemma,
be equal to the ratio of
the optimizing inputs.
And again, logically, if you
increased the input price
of factor 1, keeping
cost constant,
you would move along
this isocost line.
And you would increase
the amount of good 2
and factor 2, and decrease
the amount of factor 1.
You substitute away
from the factor, which
has now increased in price.
So in the earlier slide, lecture
4, I didn't replicate it.
We had a Walt Disney example
about machinery versus humans.
Now I'll just warn
you, it is very hard
to remember what's
divided by what.
But anyway, the fact that this
perpendicular becomes steeper
is consistent with
the input of factor 1
going down because
it's the inverse ratio.
All right, did that.
So now, how do we solve for
equilibrium factor prices?
This is just a picture
of a particular firm
and what it would do, firm j--
what it would do as we
vary the input prices?
And we want to find
particular input prices,
such that both firms
are minimizing costs,
and all the factors
get utilized.
So remember, because we have
constant returns to scale
and because we've taken the
right hand side prices as
arbitrary and given,
coming from nowhere,
say, but certainly known
to the firms, as part
of the solution,
the unit cost has
to equal to the price
for both firms 1 and 2.
So we have, from this, two
equations and two unknowns,
namely the factor prices, w1 and
w2, that we want to solve for.
So visually, we can actually
put both firm 1's and firm 2's
isocost lines on
the same diagram.
In other words,
I've gone from here,
which was firm j, and firm
j's particular isocost line--
talking about how it
varies with w1 and w2,
to this diagram, in which
we have not only firm 1--
excuse me, but also firm two.
And if we're going to
find an equilibrium,
we're going to find price for
factor 1 and a price for factor
2, each.
So each firm, in an
equilibrium, is going
to face the same factor prices.
And each firm must lie
on its own unit cost
curve equal to the price
from this equation.
So you can see the unit cost
for firm 1 equal to p 2,
the unit cost of
firm 2 equal to p2.
These are particular
isocost curves for firm 1
and firm 2 that are associated
with two of the equilibrium
equations.
And if we're going to find
common factor prices faced
by both of the
firms, we only want
one factor price for
the first factor,
and one factor price
for the second one.
So where can that
happen in this diagram?
Only one spot, and that's where
these isocost curves cross.
So this is kind of
displaying the equilibrium.
Let me say one more word about
why they're shaped in this way.
Remember, firm 1 is
intensive in factor 1.
So if we did move
along its curve,
lowering w2 and increasing w1--
because it's
intensive in factor 1,
it tends to use a
lot of factor 1.
So increasing the
price of factor 1
is kind over big
burden for firm 1.
And to compensate,
we have to lower
the price of the second
factor quite a lot,
relative to the compensation
we would have to offer firm 2.
For the same increase in w1,
the corresponding decrease in w2
is less for firm 2 than firm
1 because, again, firm 1
is intensive in factor 1.
So this factor
intensity, which I
said was a very
natural definition,
is true everywhere
by definition.
Hence, the curve for firm 1
has to be steeper everywhere
than the curve for firm 2.
And that's why
they have to cross.
Questions?
OK, so again, just
to review this slide,
we're looking for
an equilibrium.
The claim is we found
it now because we
have found the factor prices
for the first and second factor,
such that each firm is
minimizing its unit costs
associated with the cost--
the unit cost being
equal to price.
So these must be the
equilibrium quantities
of the factors being utilized
in each of the two firms.
All right, so we're kind
of doing an algorithm here.
The algorithm was define
Walrasian equilibrium.
And do that for
this 2 by 2 model.
And without telling you
that I was going to do this,
we're doing it iteratively.
The very first thing we do is
solve for the factor prices.
And now we're going to get
the quantities this way.
So the quantities,
naturally, are
going to come from a diagram
where we have isoquants.
So here we have the
input of factor 1,
the input of factor 2.
For firm j, this is an
isoquant equal production,
as you move along
that isoquant curve.
And again, you may
remember, or not,
that to minimize the cost
of producing one unit,
we find the tangency,
where the isoquant
is tangent to the isocost line.
Now again, it's a bit
dizzying because what's
an isocost line in one space
is a different-looking cost
line in another.
In this space,
the isocost curves
are concave, as I was saying.
That's in the space
of factor inputs.
W1 and W2 prices.
w1 and w2 here,
the isocost line is
linear, in the space of
input quantities, z1 and z2.
So again, the minimized cost
of producing one unit of output
here at these factor
prices, w, is this tangency.
And it's associated with the
inputs, a1 and a2, to firm, j.
And again, the
reason is something
we reviewed before,
that when you take
the derivative of the isoquant,
we're getting dz2, dz1,
the quantity is
staying the same.
So we solve for the solution.
And we're getting a relationship
between the derivative
of the isocost and the inputs.
OK, so now we want to solve,
not only for quantities,
but the equilibrium amounts.
Now remember, again, here
we were playing around
with unit costs.
But we don't know the level
of the quantities yet.
And likewise, hence, we don't
know the levels of the inputs.
Although we do know
something about the ratios
of the inputs one once we find
the equilibrium factor prices.
So having found the
equilibrium factor prices,
we now turn to
determining the inputs.
But it almost looks
like a review.
The input ratio
for firm 1 must be
those a coefficients,
the solution to the cost
minimization problem
in the quantity
space at the equilibrium
factor prices, w star.
This is true for firm 1.
It's also true for firm 2.
So the ratios of
inputs being used
must be consistent with
the optimized ratio
of inputs being used at the
equilibrium factor prices.
There are two equations there.
There's another equation,
namely that the inputs being
used by the firm, in this case,
input 1, and the second, input
2--
input 1 in firm 1,
input 1 in firm 2,
must sum up to the
aggregate endowments.
So finally, another
ingredient of the economy,
the level of the
input endowments,
is here on the right hand side.
And when we found an
equilibrium in input use,
it has to satisfy this
system of equations.
Now I can show you
a picture of it.
You may remember that
when we did production,
we talked about the
production box--
not the Edgeworth Box
of the consumer theory,
but the production box
of production theory.
We had, again,
like the isoquants,
input 1 and input 2
on the x and y-axis,
firm 1 is oriented around 01.
And we have
isoquants for firm 1.
And this ratio, the
slope of this line,
is the optimizing
ratio of inputs.
And again, that
optimizing ratio of inputs
is entirely pinned down
by the equilibrium factor
prices, which we already found.
So they have to lie on
this line somewhere.
Why here?
Because when we go up to firm
2, the same thing is true,
that the optimizing input ratio
of factor 2 to factor 1 must
lie on this line coming
out of the 02 origin.
So input ratio for
firm 1 is fixed.
Input ratio for firm 2 is fixed.
Fixed at what?
Fixed at these levels, as
in the earlier diagrams.
Hence, in an equilibrium, to be
consistent with each of them,
it must be where
these lines cross.
So this finally
determines output
because we have isoquants here.
So firm 1 is producing
on this isoquant.
Firm 2 is producing
So now we've got
both, the equilibrium
level of the inputs--
which is boom boom and
boom boom, as well as
the outputs associated
with these isoquants.
OK, are there questions so far?
Well, let me just
say, when you review,
there is a lot of
content in this lecture.
Some of it's review, as I've
already been apologizing.
Go back to lecture 4.
But also, it's kind of
stacked, in the sense
that each segment builds
on the subsequent segments.
And it's very hard
to take it in when
I go through these slides
for the first time.
But I think if you review
it the second round,
you'll see how the ingredients
are coming together.
Anyway, where are
we at this point?
We had a country,
say, an economy,
with two types of
firms, j, equal 1, 2.
We have two factors,
say labor and capital.
We had this economy facing
externally-given arbitrary
prices, p1 and p2,
for the firms 1 and 2.
And we have now solved for the
market clearing factor prices
in the input markets for the
level of the inputs being used
and the equilibrium
quantities being produced.
That's how far we got already.
OK, so now I want to
get to the trade part.
And I'm going to
add the other two.
So this is two firms, two
factors, and two countries.
And the two countries
are denoted A and B.
So each country has
the same technologies.
Each country can produce
good 1 and produce
good 2 with these factors, the
two factors, labor and capital.
We could have imagined
different technologies
in the different
countries, and in a minute,
different preferences.
You haven't seen the
consumer side of it yet.
But the famous 2 by 2 by 2
model with some amazingly cool
theorems assumes
identical technologies
and identical preferences
in the two countries.
What's different across
the two countries
are the factor endowments.
Namely, one country
is capital abundant.
The other is labor abundant.
So you might, for
example, have thought--
although this is
no longer as true
as it once was for reasons
of the theorem we're
about to see--
that countries like
Mexico or China
are relatively
well-endowed with labor.
The US, being quite
industrialized,
is relatively
well-endowed with capital.
So the US, as
distinct from Mexico,
is a capital-abundant country.
And Mexico is a
labor-abundant country.
I choose the example carefully
because, again, with NAFTA,
there's all kinds
of controversies
about what happened to the
wages of US domestic workers
when the US increased
its trade with Mexico.
We now have a theorem
that's going to tell us
something about that.
Oh, anyway, here, two countries,
A and B, with different factor
endowments-- one being
capital abundant,
and the other labor abundant.
Now, what if there's
no trade at all?
We're in autarky.
What's going to determine the
price of the consumption goods?
Well, that's where we
need the consumer part.
We're going to need the
representative consumer
in a given country
maximizing utility,
given its ownership of factors,
and potentially shares.
Although in this constant
returns to scale world,
there are no profits anyway.
So we have an entirely
domestic market,
like China completely closed
to the rest of the world.
Now we jump all the
way to free trade.
And if there's no cost
of shipping goods around,
there's an abstraction.
The price of the
two goods now have
to be the same in each
country because if there's
no cost to shipping goods
around, if the price of a good
were lower in one country
than another, then
they would basically
be exporting
a lot of that good
at a low price
to the other country
that's willing to buy it
at a high price.
So those prices
can't be different
when there's no cost to
shipping goods around.
Now exactly where
the prices are,
I will show you in a minute.
But first, let me give
you the theorem called
Heckscher-Ohlin theorem.
Suppose initially,
we're in autarky.
And neither country is trading.
And the price of the
capital-intensive good
in the capital-abundant country
will be relatively low--
relative to the price of
that capital-intensive good
in the other country.
This is intuitive in
terms of the economics.
You have a country that has a
lot of capital and relatively
little labor.
That's abundant capital.
That should drive down
the price of the capital
input, relative to the
wage of the labor input--
relative also to
the other country,
which is abundant in
labor, and should have,
because there's a lot of labor
around, a relatively low wage.
So those are the two
statements, the price
of the capital-intensive good
in the capital-abundant country
will be lower,
relative to the price
of that capital-intensive
good in the other country.
And vise versa for labor.
The price of the labor-intensive
good in the labor-abundant
country will be lower,
relative to the price of that
labor-intensive good
in the other country--
or in some, when an input is
abundant, it has a low price.
Now we go to trade.
We don't allow the
inputs to migrate.
But we do allow
trade in the goods.
Think about that first line.
The price of the
capital-intensive good
is low, relative to the price
of the capital-intensive
good in the other country.
So because it has
a low price, it
should be a, quote,
"competitive export."
So the capital-abundant
country will be exporting
the capital-intensive good.
The labor-abundant
country will be exporting
the labor-intensive good.
And we're going to find
an equilibrium where
this kind of arbitrage is
no longer profitable, where
the prices will be the same.
But the adjustment mechanism
is coming from the possibility
of exports and imports.
So let me show you
an example picture.
Suppose we have country B
here with this production
possibilities set in the
two goods, G1 and G2.
Now, I'm not telling you
exactly why it looks like this.
But it has to do with the fact
that country B is relatively
abundant in one of the factors.
You can see, relative
to country A,
this country can
produce a lot of good 2,
and relatively little of good 1.
And that's because of the
different factor intensities.
The flip side of
that is country A
over here with its production
possibility frontier.
And it can produce relatively
more of good 1 than good 2,
in the sense of enumerating
all the possibilities.
If you're in autarky--
now, you remember the
Robinson Crusoe economy
where we had Robinson
Crusoe producing two goods?
No trade-- we had, in autarky
therefore, on the island,
Robinson Crusoe's
indifference curve
would be tangent to his
production possibility set.
So this would be the autarky
allocation in country B.
Likewise, country A, with
a different technology,
a different island, so to speak,
would have another tangency
of its preference
indifference curve,
with a production
possibility set.
Now, it's kind of easier to
draw with common preferences,
having the same indifference
curve tangent in both.
But that's not a necessary
part of the argument.
All we care about is
tangency for country B
relative to its
indifference curves,
and tangency for
country A in autarky,
relative to its
indifference curves.
It just happens to be the
same indifference curve.
Now finally, we go from
autarky to free trade.
What must be the solution?
Each country-- B over here
will separate its consumption
and production problems.
It will maximize
profits by finding
the point on its production
possibility frontier
which gives it the
highest level of profits,
as captured by this
budget line, really--
trade line, that emanates
from the new change production
point.
And I know the old
production point was autarky
for country B. It's now shifted
to be giving up some of good 1,
and producing more of good
2, and then exporting good 2
and getting more of good 1 back.
So it specializes
more in production.
And then achieves
balance in consumption
by imports and exports.
And country A down here
is doing the opposite.
It specialized
more in production
in the other direction,
more of good 1,
and then trades in the world
economy, giving up good 1
and getting good 2.
And although it's not drawn
here, the exports of good 1
for country A are exactly
equal to the imports of good 1
for country B. So the prices
of the goods associated
with this external
price line are
the same for both
countries, and have
the property that, finally,
we have an equilibrium
in the goods markets.
In sum, we've now made
the prices endogenous.
P1 and 2, which were given
throughout 3/4 of the lecture,
are now determined
internationally by free trade.
All right, so we
did Heckscher-Ohlin.
Now we have another theorem,
Stopler-Samuelson theorem.
In this 2 by 2 by 2 model
with these varying factor
intensities, if the price
of good i increases,
then the equilibrium
price of the factor
that's used more
intensively in good i
also increases, while the price
of the other factor decreases.
So let me say it again.
And let me give the
motivation here.
We're going from autarky
in each country one
at a time, with its
internal domestic prices,
to an equilibrium
in the world economy
with free trade at
different prices.
So for country b
here, P1 over P2
is going down, relative to what
it will be in the free trade
equilibrium.
And the reverse is
true for country A.
So when we go from
autarky to trade,
we're moving the price
ratio in both countries--
in different directions,
but we're moving it.
So let's say, what is the
impact now of moving a price?
If we increase the price of good
i relative to the other good,
the equilibrium
price of the factor
that was used more intensively
in the production of good i
will increase, while the
price of the other factor
will decrease.
OK, so let's go back to a proof
of this in the earlier diagram,
setting aside the two countries,
kind of not asking for a minute
where the price comes from--
except that where previously we
had these isocost
lines crossing,
the cost lines associated
with P1 and P2--
we now increase the
price of good 1.
So C1 equal to P1 is here.
C1 equal to P prime
1 lies further out.
It kind of stands
to reason that it
should lie further out because
we've increased the price.
And we want cost equal to price.
So if price is higher,
cost can be higher.
And cost can be higher by having
higher levels of w1 and w2
as the input prices.
So the isocost
line for the price
when the price increases,
in this case, good 1's price
increases, shifts outward.
We haven't done anything to
the price of the other good.
The C2-- where is it?
The C2 line is staying constant.
The C2 isocost line of price
B2 is staying constant.
However, we need a crossing--
that an equilibrium
is described by where
the lines cross.
So we would move from
this initial crossing
to this second crossing.
And you can see,
as a consequence
of the increase in price in P1,
that the price of factor 1--
good 1 is intensive in factor 1.
That's the definition that we
were given at the beginning.
The price of good 1 increases.
Therefore, the
input, which is used
intensively in good 1, namely
factor 1, should increase.
And the other one decreases.
So this diagram illustrates
the Stopler-Samuelson theorem.
But again, in the
context of free trade,
those price movements
come about for a reason.
Namely, we've gone from
autarky to free trade.
So you could see earlier which
way the price was moving,
depending on the initial
country and the autarky.
Now, although we
know, again, to repeat
the steps of the
algorithm, we now
know what happens
to the factor prices
from this diagram, what happens
to the levels of the inputs,
and what happens to output.
Well, we have this,
again, box for production.
We had the initial allocation
ratio of the factors
as quantities crossed.
That is to say, the line for
good 1 and the line for good 2
crossed.
And they crossed here.
But now those factor
prices have changed.
As a consequence of
the price change,
the quantity of the
first factor will go down
because its price has gone up
from country 1's point of view.
That produces a somewhat
steeper sloped line.
And the opposite is
going on with country 2.
So the new equilibrium is
where these now-changed slope
lines cross.
And you can actually
see, in this case,
that firm 1 is producing more
because its isoquant will
be higher.
And it's using a higher
level of both inputs.
And likewise, the production
of good 2 will contract.
So again, this factor price
equalization theorem is,
just to restate it, in the
2 by 2 and 2-country model,
as long as we have this factor
intensity assumption holding
and the countries are not
completely specialized,
the equilibrium price
of factors, inputs,
only depends on the technologies
and on the output prices--
determined as it may
be, in such a way
that the prices of the outputs
equals the input costs.
But now, look, if both
countries face the same prices
because they trade in
goods, and otherwise there
would be arbitrage, then
since the prices are
the same in both countries, we
can zero inside each country,
and look at the factor prices,
which are clearing the factor
markets in each country.
And since each country
has the same technology,
these equations across the two
goods in each country hold.
If the prices are the
same on the right hand
side as a consequence
of free trade,
then the solution
to the input prices
has to be the same on
the left hand side.
So in short, remarkably, we have
not allowed trade in factors--
no migration.
But we've managed to equalize
factor prices without migration
simply by having trade in goods.
So that's the famous factor
price equalization theorem.
So vis a vis, the US and Mexico,
allowing the NAFTA, free trade
in goods, even with
a wall, if I dare
say, prohibiting
Mexican migration,
the theorem says that the wages
in Mexico should rise in Mexico
and fall to the US, to the point
that the wages are the same.
So the factors
bear consequences.
It's not necessarily a good
thing that wages of labor
are falling in the US--
not good for those firms.
We have to come back
to those households.
to the welfare theorems
to think about the winners
and losers from trade.
The point here only is that you
can see why there is sometimes
resistance to trade because
trade does have consequences
for factor prices.
Hence, for the welfare of the
providers of those factors,
depending on whether they're
capitalists that own wealth,
capital that's used in
machinery and so on,
versus laborers that have
only their labor endowment.
OK, so next time we're going
to go with this kind of theorem
back to the Thai villages.
And then we're going to go,
in the subsequent lecture,
to the US, and
explore these ideas.
OK, that's all I have for today.
OK, thank you very much.